für boris becker ist es der vierte abend
im berüchtigten englischen gefängnissen
smith und inzwischen wissen wir auch wo
er dort untergebracht ist bei mir ist
mit live show chefin der janina
christiani navi schauen hier auf die
bilder erklärt uns wo er ist genau wir
sehen hier schon den flügel e also
dieses ganze gefängnis besteht im
prinzip sieht aus wie ein stern die
ganzen flügel sind nummeriert abc.de und
ersetzt in flügel das ist quasi der
trakt in denen die neuankömmlinge in dem
die neuankömmlinge sind die werden dort
untergebracht hier sehen wir einmal
diese rotonde da laufen quasi die wie
ein stern laufen diese trakte da
zusammen und hier sehen wir jetzt
wirklich von innen auch nochmal trakte
und dort bekommt er jetzt quasi seine
jack nast einführung kann man es ja
quasi schon nennen also er wird geprüft
welche regeln gibt es dort in diesem
knast hier sehen wir noch mal diese
blauen türen die dann wirklich auch
nachts verschlossen werden ein
gefängnisinsasse hat uns gesagt dass man
eigentlich den ganzen tag dort drin ist
weil es wenig freizeitaktivitäten gibt
und der brandschutz gefahr man wird
aufgeklärt wo man sich hinwenden kann
wenn man denn psychische probleme hat
und ein ex-knacki hat uns auch erzählt
dass dieser bereich beirut genannt wird
dann man hört die anderen insassen dort
teilweise schreien denn dort sind halt
eben nicht nur häftlinge die ganz neu
angekommen sind sondern auch menschen
die zum beispiel einen drogenentzug
machen oder psychische probleme haben
also eine gespenstische erfahrung da im
block evobus jetzt ist und so eine
einführung kann tatsächlich bis zu einer
woche dauern denn dort werden die
insassen tatsächlich auch isoliert bis
sie dann in den haupttrakt kommen und
das kann eine woche dauern lasst uns für
unseren reporter john puthenpurackal
dazuholen der diesen prozess in london
beobachtet hat der dabei war als dieses
dramatische urteil gesprochen wurde john
was wissen wir zu boris zelle ist er da
alleine oder hat er einen zellengenossen
ersten medienberichten zufolge soll er
aktuell allein im märz soll es sein das
wird sich aber schnell ändern man muss
wissen was worth das zweitgrößte
gefängnis hier in london ist ziemlich
überfüllt eigentlich sind diese zellen
nur für eine person gebaut worden aber
aufgrund der fülle aufgrund der vielen
gefangenen die jeden tag für herr
angeliefert werden müssen sich die
gefangenen inzwischen eine zelle teilen
das heißt boris becker wird auf kurz
oder lang mit einer zweiten person diese
zelle teilen müssen die aber nicht kennt
gebe team zu gehören nun haben wir schon
so viele schaurige geschichten gehört
auch dass der abfluss nicht richtig
funktioniert werden bilder von innen
gesehen vielleicht können wir die auch
noch mal zeigen von diesem jahr zimmer
kann man das ja gar nicht nennen es ist
halt einfach eine zelle wahnsinnig klein
die toilette direkt neben dem bett gibt
es da irgendwie sowas wie putzkräfte
oder müssen dass die insassen selber
sauber halten
na ja das ist ja kein hotel es ist eines
der härtesten gefängnisse hier in london
es gibt keine
ganz im gegenteil die gefangenen sind
selbst darauf angewiesen ihre zelle zu
reinigen und soweit ich das ist von
anderen
gefangenen und ex häftlingen erfahren
habe gibt es teilweise nichtmal
putzmittel dazu um seine zelle sauber zu
machen man muss improvisieren das heißt
zum einen vielleicht muss man
toilettenpapier nehmen man muss
vielleicht seine eigene zahnbürste
nehmen wie es das ist ihm schlecht
gefühlen dass man teilweise dann sich
selber darum kümmern muss dass diese
zelle eben wieder quasi gereinigt werden
kann wie auch immer und für boris becker
bleibt nur zu hoffen dass seine wächter
quasi tennisfans oder ihn mögen und
ihnen gegebenenfalls als mittel zur
verfügung stehe auch faktisch boris
becker ist für die reinigung seiner
zelle selber verantworten tennisfans in
tenniskleidung wird er dort nicht
rumlaufen wir müssen wir uns das
vorstellen trägt er da so an den euro
ein anzug
also nicht so wie im us film sondern es
sind graue jogginganzüge teilweise zu
klein teilweise ist da noch der schweiß
von gefangenen zu riechen die den vorher
getragen haben denn in ronsdorf so hört
man herrscht teilweise noch chaos bei
der organisation bei der reinigung nicht
nur der zellen sondern auch bei der
wäsche und boris becker trägt nach
unseren informationen wie jeder häftling
dort einen grauen anzug
es ist aber auch nicht wie in
amerikanischen filmen dass da irgendwie
der nummer drauf ist oder so ist sondern
es ist einfach ein farbloser wie mir
auch beschrieben wurde eklige anzug
nun ist boris becker bekanntlich raucher
wir wissen aber auch dass man im
gefängnis eigentlich auf alles
verzichten muss darf er noch rauchen das
ist eine
komische frage möglicherweise aber ich
weiß dass es nicht ganz einfach es an
zigaretten zu kommen im knast
also grundsätzlich gilt dass die dass
das britische justizministerium
2017 in allen britischen gefängnissen
verboten hat zu rauchen das hat zu
enormen unruhen in den gefängnissen
geführt und auch in mannswörth denn das
brauchen ist sozusagen der alle liebste
zeitvertreib und häftlingen so hat man
dann ein jahr später
quasi den konsum von e zigaretten
erlaubt denn dennoch hab ich dann gehört
was häftlinge trotzdem immer noch in den
zellen rauchen und wenn beckers darauf
anlegen möchte und gerne tabakrauchen
möchte kann er das auf dem schwarzmarkt
kaufen da gibt es häftlinge die tabak
dort anbieten doch das wird ganz schön
teuer man sagt dazu dass man bis zu 1000
euro für tabak aber
auch für ein blättchen allein 15 pfund
zahlen muss das jetzt also eine sache so
weit ich das den heftigen verstanden
habt da gibt es leute die sich da enorm
verschulden und das kann eine
schuldenfalle werden sollte lieber e
zigaretten bleiben kurze frage noch zum
schluss in deutschland sind die meinung
ja durchaus gespalten die einen sagen es
ist ein verurteilter straftäter
nichts gelernt in den letzten 20 jahren
seitdem er ja schon mal verurteilt
worden war und richtig so dass er in den
knast muss die anderen haben mitleid und
sagen mensch dass es doch unser boris
wie ist das in england dort ist ja auch
sehr bekannt
ja das ist wie du schon sagst ja auch
hier eine sehr gemischte stimmung ich
ernähre mich am wochenende einer
aufmachung von der tageszeitung the
mirror die dann ein bild genommen haben
von boris becker als er damals als
17-jähriger dem wimmelten das wimbledon
turnier gewonnen hat und da drunter war
dann ganz groß die unterschrift sam und
daneben war dann eine zeichnung von ihm
aus dem gericht und da stand dann jump
und samt steht für trottel das zeigt so
ein bisschen die bandbreite der gefühle
der briten aber wenn ich dann zum
beispiel ein roger kay denke den
bekannten autor der daily mail das gibt
man kann ihm nicht böse sein er ist kein
verbrecher aber er hat einfach nicht die
gabe dazu gehabt mit seinen schmerzen
umzugehen und daher ich kann nur sagen
grundsätzlich nicht die sympathien zu
aber man sagt die strafe ist gerecht
dort boten pokal aus london vielen dank
ich habe im gegensatz zu elias elfer
boris beckers ältester sohn janina noah
im gericht dabei als das urteil
gesprochen wurde mit seiner tochter anna
ermakova haben wir beide direkt im
anschluss an das urteil gesprochen sie
zeigte sich schockiert hat gesagt sie
will ihren vater so oft wie möglich
besuchen aber jetzt wollen wir dann mal
schauen was ist eigentlich mit seinem
jüngsten sohn amadeus
weiß amadeus dass sein vater boris
becker ein verurteilter straftäter ist
dass sein geliebter vater für ein jahr
und drei monate im knast sitzen wird
dass er sein großes vorbild lange nicht
in freiheit erleben wird wer hilft
amadeus in diesen schweren zeiten
es ist der enge freundeskreis weiß auch
bild unterhaltungschefin tanja may lilly
hatte einen sehr engen freundeskreis und
die freunde von amadeus das ist wie so
eine kleine wagenburg im moment um ihn
herum und lilly und die mütter der
anderen kinder die haben also schon in
den tagen des prozesses vereinbart dass
man eben nichts an die kinder heran
trägt damit die jungs nicht sagen herr
matthäus was mit dem papa los wann kommt
papa wieder wo ist papa das sind die
fragen die lilly becker ihrem sohn
amadeus beantworten muss oder bereits
beantwortet hat wie schafft eine mutter
dass es geht eben nicht darum dem kind
zu sagen das sind alle unfehlbar oder
wir müssen uns jetzt verurteilen da
wären das was ganz schlimmes gemacht 100
zusagen hier sind alles menschen und wir
können lernen wir können uns besser aber
es gibt natürlich auch konsequenzen für
negatives verhalten und genau das ist
jetzt vielleicht dem papa passiert so
wie du das auch kennst rückblick am
donnerstag sehen sich boris und amadeus
vor haftantritt das letzte mal die
tennis legende boris becker gibt amadeus
einen kuss auf die stirn zum abschied
natürlich weil das foto ist wirklich
sehr anrührend wie models von seinem
jüngsten sohn verabschiedet aber unsere
informationen sind dass der kleine gar
keine ahnung hatte was da passiert und
auch lilly fest davon ausgegangen ist
dass bau des nicht ins gefängnis muss
für boris ist es ein abschiedskuss für
lange zeit für amadeus aber nur ein
alltägliches abschieds ritual wenn auch
voller liebe und zuneigung
wie kann es sein dass ein zwölf jahre
alter junge so in ungewissheit gelassen
wird ist das sinnvoll ist das richtig
seit beides vor und nachteile zu dem
zeitpunkt war ja auch noch nicht klar ob
es wirklich die finale trennung geben
wie jetzt von daher könnte hätte man da
auch eventuelle ängste des kindes führen
können die dann vielleicht unbegründet
gewesen wären jetzt ist die situation
eine andere
jetzt ist es wichtig mit ihm wirklich in
die offenheit zu gehen und ihm wirklich
zu sagen was das bedeutet und wie wird
amadeus darauf reagieren dass er sich
nicht von seinem vater verabschieden
konnte hätte er vielleicht seinem vater
kraft geben können und wollen für die
ersten tage im gefängnis alle aus der
bäckerfamilie machen sich derzeit größte
sorgen um amadeus auch seine
stiefschwester
helfen wie ich kann
ans gericht geschrieben um klarzustellen
dass man danach wieder mann halb oder
matthäus s12 und sich vorstellen dass
ich mich um ihn sorge
vaterfigur fehlen und jetzt ist ja eine
essentielle zeit im leben an sieben
menschen so ganz wird der kontakt
zwischen amadeus und seinem vater wohl
nicht abreißen
viermal im monat für eine stunde kann
boris besuch empfangen und gerade in
seiner größten niederlage kann boris
becker jetzt ein vorbild sein für
amadeus ihm zeigen dass fehler und
dunkle zeiten zum leben dazugehören
die frage ist natürlich schöner kann man
das tatsächlich
geheim halten vor dem jungen geht die
auch in die schule irgendwie spricht
sich das ja immer um natürlich und
selbst wenn lilly wie wir wissen gerade
versucht ihn so ein bisschen zu
isolieren und auch mit den eltern
gesprochen hat dass die ihren kindern
nichts sagen damit die kinder das
wiederum nicht an den amadeus weiter
tragen muss man doch sagen da braucht
doch nur ein bully kommen also einer der
irgendwie amadeus nicht mag der denn in
der schule sagt ekici dein papa ist im
knast und dann platzt diese bombe also
ich bin mir auch ziemlich sicher dass
lilly ihnen das jetzt ihnen das jetzt
die nächsten tage möglicherweise sogar
schon die nächsten stunden sagen wird
denn so lange kann man das nicht
geheimhalten von lilli zu lilien das war
die junge frau an seiner seite die ihn
auch begleitet hat in den gerichtssaal
hinaus musste dann hinein musste dann
aber alleine wieder hinausgehen müssen
wir irgendwas was sie ausmacht wo sie
ehrte was wir sehen hier noch mal die
bilder vom freitagmorgen beide zusammen
hand in hand sie seine größte stütze
wirklich während des ganzen prozesses
und dann diese dramatik sie wenige
stunden später geht sie alleine aus dem
gerichtssaal heraus dann kommen die
fotografen belagern sie natürlich hier
sieht man noch mal diese ganze dramatik
mit der sonnenbrille
sie wollte natürlich nicht dass man ihre
verweinten augen sieht und jetzt wird
sie hier gestützt von einer freundin auf
dem weg in kern sinken zu der wohnung in
der sie zusammen mit boris becker gelebt
hat und in der sie sich laut unseren
informationen jetzt auch noch aufhalten
soll sie ist abgetaucht so haben wir aus
dem umfeld gehört abgetaucht im sinne
von sie wird sich ein bisschen ein hier
sehen wir noch mal den eingang zu der
wohnung denn sie möchte das ganze jetzt
einfach auch erstmal verarbeiten und vor
allen dingen möchte sie schauen dass sie
boris dann ganz bald im knast besuchen
kann dann aber natürlich auch ohne
medienrummel und wir haben auch aus
kreisen von boris becker erfahren dass
es eine liste geben soll eine
besucherliste auf die boris namen
geschrieben hat also wer darf ihn im
knast besuchen wer darf ihn überhaupt
kontaktieren die hat er selber verfasst
diese liste und auf dieser liste da sind
wir uns sehr sehr sicher wird natürlich
auch lilien draufstehen und
höchstwahrscheinlich auch seine kinder
tochter anna hat es ja bei uns exklusiv
im interview auch schon angekündigt dass
sie ihn besuchen möchte aber lilien
jetzt momentan
untergetaucht zeigt sich nicht in der
öffentlichkeit hält sich aber laut
unseren informationen in london auf sie
möchte diese dinge die da jetzt passiert
sind das ist für sie natürlich auch ein
großer schock die vsg 33 das muss jetzt
alles erstmal verarbeiten und dafür
wünschen wir natürlich viel kraft berlin
aktiv vielen dank für die einheiten im
studio